بالعوده الى شان الاوكراني مع استمرار
المعارك واقرار كياف بصعوبات على الجبهه
نسلط الضوء على مساعدات عسكريه محتمله
لاوكرانيا من دول الغرب وتحديدا الولايات
المتحده تنقل رويترز عن مصادر مطلعه ان
البنتاجون يدرس اقتراحا لتزويد اوكرانيا
بقنا بلا دقيقه صغيره يجري تثبيتها على
صواريخ والقنابل ذات القطر الصغير التي
تطلق من الارض موجهه بنظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي جي بي اس ويمكنها التغلب على بعض
انواع التشويش الالكترونيه كما يمكن
استخدامها في جميع ظروف الطقس رغم ان
الولايات المتحده رفضت طلبات لتوفير
صواريخ يناهز مداها 300 كلم فانا مدى
القنابل المحل البحث يبلغ 150 كلم
تجمع المنظومه بين قنبله 39
في القطر الصغير ومحرك الصواريخ ام 26
ومحركات الصواريخ امس 26 متوفره بكثره
نسبيا وتبلغ تكلفه جي بي يو 39 نحو 40000
دولار للقطعه الواحده وهما يجعل القنابل
غير باهظه الثمن ومكوناتها الرئيسيه متاحه
وجاهزه وجيبيو 99 التي ستؤدي وظيفه الراس
الانفجاري للقنابل لا جناحان صغيران مطويه
يسمحان لها بالتحرك لاكثر من 100 كلم عند
القائها من الطائره يتيح مدى القنابل محل
البحث والذي يبلغ 150 كيلو مترا يتيح
لاوكرانيا ضرب اهداف عسكريه حيويه كان من
الصعب الوصول اليها فضلا عن مساعدتها في
مواصلاتها هجماتها المضاده لكن من اين
ستاتي الاسلحه
الاجابه في وثيقه حصلت عليها رويترز
وتتضمن مقترحا من شركه بوينج الى القياده
العسكريه الامريكيه في اوروبا والتي تشرف
على الاسلحه الموجهه لاوكرانيا اشير
الوثيقه الى ان المكونات الرئيسيه للقنابل
محل البحث ستاتي من المخزون الامريكيه
الحالي الثمن غير الباهظ وتوفر المكونات
من العوامل المساعده على انتاج اسلحه
بحلول مطلع عام 2000 و 2023 ويمكن تسليم
هذه القنابل في وقت مبكرا من ربيعي العام
نفسه لم تكشف ورشه رسميه حتى اللحظه عن
خطه تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الاسلحه لكن
متحدثا باسم البنت قال ان الولايات
المتحده
وحلفاءها تفكرون في انسب الانظمه التي من
شانها ان تساعد سياف منظومه التسليح
المقترحه التي تتحدث عنها رويترز هي واحده
من ست خطط ينتج تاخيره جديده اوكرانيا
وحلفاء واشنطن في اوروبا الشرقيه كما تقول
مصادر في صناعه الاسلحه الامريكيه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بك لواء فايز هذه الانظمه الجديده
التي يتم البحث بها والحديث عنها كيف من
شانها ان تبدل في موازين القوى وتعطي قوه
اكبر لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
انا اتصل فيه ربيع 2023 هاي بمعنى اخر بعد
تقريبا اربعه اشهر من العالم وهذا وهذه
فتره زمنيه ليست همم بالقصيره في ظل
الاحتياجات الان السلاح الرئيسي الذي
يستخدم في قضاء خمارش لغايه 80 كيلو متر
واا ادت دورها بشكل فاعل جدا ولكن يبدو ان
المخزونات الرئيسيه اللي مارس بدات
تتاثر وبالتالي حسب منظومه الامداد
الامريكي نظام الامداد الخط الاول والثاني
لا يمكن المساس به والذهاب الى الخط
الثالث همم الان همم مارس المشكله
الرئيسيه
حجم الانتاج السنوي
4600 صاروخ
بعد المصادر ذكرت انه تم ارسال خمسه الاف
يعني اكثر من انتاج عام كامل تم ارساله
وبالتالي بدا البحث عن هذا الموضوع في عام
2019 ليس من الان من اجل عمليه المزاوجه
ما بين المحرك
7 وما بين الصاروخ جي بي يو 39 من عام
2019 بدا العمل همم في التعاون ما بين
شركه شاب
وشركه بوينج الان همم النقطه المثيره
للاهتمام المدى نتحدث عن مدى 150 كيلو متر
فاذا كان هيمارس قدم هذه الخدمات الكبيره
وادى الى انجاح عمليات القوات الاوكرانيه
في تركيا في همم
خيرسون وقدم
كثير لهذه المعارك هذا السلاح تقريبا ضعف
المسافه بمعنى اخر انه سيغطي كافه المنطقه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه لا بل يصل الى داخل
الجغرافيا الروسيه
الانظمه انظمه السلاح التي يصل مداها الى
150 كلم اليوم كانت لافته تغريده لمستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني يقول فيها ثلاثه امور
صواريخ باتريوت اف 16
ولا بارد هذا ما يطالب به الجانب
الاوكراني حاليا ما فرص ان يحصل على كل
ذلك
حتى هذه اللحظه حتى هذه اللحظه التي اتحدث
فيها هناك تحافظ امريكي
قدم عرضا بديلا صواريخ حكم محسن صواريخ
حكم حسن وصواريخ
الروسيه يوجد بطاريه في المخزونات
الامريكيه حصلت عليها اثناء فتره تفكك
الاتحاد السوفيتي فاعتبر ان صواريخ
الهجريه الاف 16 حتى هذه اللحظه تعتبر خط
احمر دبابه اليو بارك او ابرامز كذلك تقع
ضمن الخط الاحمر هو في هذا في يوم امس
طلبوا من التوانيا دبابات وغير ذلك لكن
يبدو انها لا تزال تعتبر اسلحه هجوميه وهي
مصممه للادوار الهجوميه وليست للادوار
الدفاعيه وبالتالي
هذا الامر يعتبر نقطه فارغه وبالتالي همم
تعتبر روسيا دخول مباشر في المواجهه
العسكريه باختصار شديد لواء فايز انظمه
راجمات صواريخ من فرنسا جرى تسليمها الى
اوكرانيا كيف ايضا من شانها ان تؤثر على
مسار المعارك
تم
ارسال من فرنسا ومن المانيا ليس يعني مارس
2 وام تو 7 ودفاع جوي كروتال هذه ولكنها
بكميات محدوده جدا يعني الان همم عندما
يتم ارسال ثلاث مدافع من المانيا ماذا
ستقدم يعني الان هذه الحرب كما يقال اكله
الاخضر واليابس وبالتالي لا حضر المساعدات
الامريكيه ان تحدث عن خمسه الاف صاروخ
هيمارس الان عندما يتم تزويدهم بثلاثه
مدافع هاوزر من هنا او براجمتي صاروخ من
هناك طب يعني يبقى مساعده رمزيه اكثر منها
مساعده حقيقيه لقلب موازين المعركه
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتي